alchemy is sort of a crypto
infrastructure company it aims to be
what's known as the the amazon web
services of web 3.0 web 3.0 is a term
used to describe
different types of applications and
software programs that run on top of
blockchains instead of the decentralized
servers that operate google and facebook
and those types of companies
amazon has two businesses they have
their shopping business and they have
another business and that business is
called amazon web services and it powers
pretty much every product on the
internet and it's actually two-thirds of
amazon's profits and over a trillion
dollar company on its own alchemy is the
same thing as these developer platforms
but for the blockchain industry we power
you know virtually every nft in the
world uh the majority of the large
companies in the space and we enable
people to build applications on the
blockchain alchemy calls itself the
amazon web services of of crypto because
as opposed to offering a like a consumer
focused product they offer a business to
business service with a software stack
that helps developers easily build
applications that run on top of these
blockchains the blockchain networks and
the applications need to find a way to
talk to each other and interact and
alchemy provides a handy out-of-the-box
solution to make that simple so
developers can focus on building
intuitive and fun applications for users
when we started our total market size
market size not our revenue was like 5
million if you really squinted you could
see it as 10 million so
we was very early but we said look we
have a chance to build one of these
developer platforms that could really
power the space and this is what we're
excited about doing so that's how
alchemy started
alchemy is a relatively small company
has under 50 employees but i don't think
that it's very unusual in silicon valley
the company did raise a significant
amount of money this year i believe its
valuation now is at 3.5 billion dollars
and i anticipate the company scaling up
and out as it tries to put the money to
to could use that protected market share
and grow into other verticals
probably this time last year it was like
100 million valuation and it just went
up because everything in crypto has gone
crazy the large valuation really is a
reflection of the excitement and and
growing usage of of blockchains this
year be it nfts via d5 applications more
and more users are getting involved in
crypto they are participating and using
blockchain applications to to buy and
sell assets play games store data and
all of that has to operate on software
that's secure resilient and efficient
alchemy through its solution to help
applications run on top of blockchains
is in a very critical point in many ways
it is a keystone to the crypto ecosystem
so
i would expect that the the growth of
the company's valuation would be highly
correlated to overall adoption in crypto
right now we do about 30 billion dollars
in transactions for pretty much every
country in the world and tens of million
users around the planet and most nfts in
the world are powered by alchemy
over the next several years what we
really hope to do is help grow and
expand the blockchain industry and
really bring this technology to everyone
around the planet
blockchains can can be difficult to to
interact with and on top of that
many applications today be it a an
exchange a marketplace a payments
program a data storage company there's a
different set of challenges when it
comes to building an application that
will run on top of a gene like ethereum
versus one such as algorand or cardano
or or solana and an alchemy makes those
things simple so that the teams building
these products are able to focus on what
they do best a lot of the early
programmers would just build their
applications directly on top of the
blockchains and alchemy i think
represents a maturity in the space where
this type of middleware is now important
from a young age i knew i wanted to do
software building consumer products
then what happened is we had seen crypto
and blockchain and there was a you know
when you look at these big ships and
technology the computer the internet
blockchain each one gives you a new
building block the computer enables you
to say machines can now follow human
instructions never before was that
possible internet gives you new building
block and that building block is the
ability for machines to exchange
information blockchain comes along and
says okay now machines can exchange
value we saw that and said if you were
early in industry you have the chance to
build a really foundational company you
know like an apple microsoft did for the
computing industry we didn't know if it
was going to be big but we said it could
be big and we have we have a thought
that it could be big
one of the big things that alchemy is
going to need to do is continue to grow
build out its workforce so they can
support an ever wider array of
blockchains and applications on top of
blockchains and also provide expert
customer service because blockchains are
supposed to be immutable they're
supposed to run 24 7 365 without issues
um that can become problematic so so
alchemy is going to have to continue to
provide the same level of service that
they've given to their earlier clients
and that is a common trend that i see
among a lot of crypto startups they're
always trying to
weigh the uh in some ways conflicting
impulses to grow but also to scale you
can't grow too much too fast but at the
same time if you if you don't grow
someone else is going to and and there's
another very big group of company that
is also trying to stay claimed to the
title of the aws of crypto and that's
coinbase
coinbase as most people know went public
this year via direct listing on nasdaq
in april of the largest direct listing
in history with an 86 billion dollar
valuation
it's the largest exchange in the us it's
the most well-known exchange in the u.s
the company announced that it was going
to be launching an nft marketplace and
got over a million signups for the wait
list on the very first day
and coinbase acquired a company called
bison trails which is a similar type of
infrastructure company to alchemy
it's not quite as robust it doesn't have
the same level of technical
sophistication right now or or the same
type of fully fledged product suite but
they're building it and they have the
advantage of of being part of coinbase
so anything that they build be it
applications that run on top of the
network or applications that interact
with coinbase's software it comes with a
a full-fledged integrated customer
experience
that most people are already familiar
with i mean coinbase has tens of
millions of verified users and that's
certainly something to take very
seriously
you